the editors of science robotics have
chosen the most exciting robotic
technologies for 2018 here are just some
of the big innovations from last year a
new video of the world's most dynamic
humanoid shows Boston Dynamics Atlas
jumping over a log with one leg and
bounding up increasingly higher wooden
boxes without braking pace these feats
add to walking on challenging terrain
lifting and manipulating objects and
executing a backflip like a gymnast for
this latest parkour type behavior the
control software uses the arms legs and
torso to manage energy Atlas also has a
novel visual sensing system to judge
each leap although these behaviors are
not achieved for all trials the
demonstrations serve as an inspiration
for what robots can do in the near
future this tailless flapping robot is a
perfect example of bio-inspired design
design that helps both to develop new
technologies and to unveil the secrets
of how nature builds living things
surprisingly this bot can accurately
reproduce the rapid escape manoeuvres of
fruit flies even with no explicit
control of all of its rotational axes
and although it's over 50 times the size
of a fruit fly and doesn't mimic the
wing morphology or kinematics of any
specific natural flyer it shows that the
bot can serve as a physical model to
test how flying organisms control flight
the editors consider it a paradigmatic
example of science for robotics and
robotics for science and expect that it
will advance the development of all
flying robots
this year we saw a self-assembling
DNA origami structure that can be moved
precisely by externally applied electric
field that means nanoscale DNA robots
can be controlled by a macro level
switch molecular robots like these can
be used for transport of molecules or
nanoparticles over tens of nanometers
and open the door to programmable
synthesis and assembly of materials from
the bottom up if you need an exoskeleton
to help you move you probably don't want
it to be as heavy as Iron Man's a new
lightweight stretchy exosuit offers new
ways of integrating fabric design
sensing robotic control and actuation to
increase the wearer's strength balance
and endurance and human-in-the-loop
control plus better integration with
natural movement the return of I bow
first introduced nearly 20 years ago by
Sony brings increasing awareness of the
role social robots can play in childhood
learning or as companions for the Aged
understanding the perceptions
interactions and expectations of the
people around the robot and developing
robot behaviors and personalities that
are context aware are key challenges of
social robotics
[Music]